here at the Best Buy and they have a
wall up and it just shocked me now the
reality of this epidemic of cancer and
usually I often think someone older up
in age but look at these long tiny
children look at that it's all kids
these are all kids all kids it doesn't
stop it just keeps going all the way
here these are all kids with cancer
do you think like what is going on kids
with cancer look at that these are their
names
obviously the faces are repetitive but
everyone has their own individual name
so these pictures is the same picture
just a kid but the name differentiates
it's a individual unique to themselves
so everyone here look at that these are
kids man that's why I've been so
passionate about trying to help families
people really take this serious our
health and blessing from Allah that he
gave us the lifestyle that we're living
and the connection to what we're putting
in this gift that Allah gave us our
bodies the fake food and any of the
other toxins that are even reflecting
children need to wake up and take this
reality serious get informed get
educated and start doing what you can
today to do us in your power to protect
yourself and your children your families
take the matter serious appreciate the
blessing of Health before us our
families lose it and then we put our
trust in the Almighty Allah but we do
what we can that's in our power
did you see all those kids okay so
you're like thinking like okay Eddie
what can I do
okay look you know the hadith of the
Prophet SAW some said you know the man
came in the Masjid and he said okay I
left my camel out there what should I do
so I just leave it out there untied and
just put my trust in Allah no he said go
tie the camel and then put your trust in
Allah so you do everything you can to
preserve the vehicle that Allah gave you
to get through life so before you put
something in or you allow something in
your body or your children's body you
just don't blindly put it in just like
you know all of the the the garbage
processed junk foods you think like okay
if I'm allowing my children to eat foods
that are directly affecting the body in
a negative way pops and these cereal
boxes and you know the sugar the cookies
cakes and the ice cream all of these
things that are cancer-causing elements
they help to cancer to grow in your body
do you understand am i creating a sugar
addict with my child and I'm projecting
my food preferences on my kids so what I
like now it's garbage and then I'm
destroying my kids helps also you want
your kids you do you want your kid to
have their face up there as another
victim someone says well come on you
know I just put my trust in Allah it
doesn't work like that
you do everything that you can in your
power to protect yourself and your
family and then you know that no one can
be protected I said by laws permission
but you did everything in your power so
brothers and sisters don't allow this
garbage
this fake food in the mustards let's
start from there there's my brother was
telling me that some people have caught
on and they're really taking this to a
whole loved another level they're not
allowing what's normally you know the
peeps are the cake and the ice creams
all look if it's baked with something
some natural organic ingredients okay
but Coke Pepsi Diet Pepsi the fruit
juice all of this stuff investigate it
see for yourselves a really great
documentary called fed up I encourage
everybody to watch it there's another
great documentary the truth about cancer
episode one watch it
there are so many health documentaries
there are so many independent studies so
many researchers so many holistic
doctors so many people who really are
out there informing the people but
you're not going to come across this
information unless you're taking the
matter serious and you're looking for it
so are you looking for it are you just
going along with everyone putting
whatever garbage in your body buying all
the garbage all the junk and then you
know you wonder why my kids sick why I
have to be taking them to the doctor
eating the fake food taking the fake
drugs the fake medicine and then you
wonder what's the preventive medicine
that you guard your health by protecting
your health not letting anything toxic
or any any of these processes junked
fake foods into your home into your
cupboards watch what you're cooking with
you're not eating at McDonald's Burger
King you're not you're you're you're
watching which you're baking with what
you're cooking with basic simple things
but I leave leave people with a simple
message eat real food
avoid fake food if you look at the
things look bananas days you have a
whole variety of fruits and vegetables
meats halau obviously but from grass-fed
animals right and then you look at
what's a fake food a fake food is
anything that has a list of ingredients
that you can't recognize you cannot
pronounce the stuff don't allow it into
your bodies don't allow into your house
and this is the the small things that we
can do right on top of you know the
beautiful Heidi for the profits awesome
had talked up
you know enough for the son of Adam is
just eating a few morsels fuse snacks to
keep you going upright if you're over
taking 1/3 1/3 1/3 1/3 1/3 or 1/3 water
but alongside with that is doing that
with real food not fake food poison
toxic food that is affecting the body
and then you have all these diseases
that are coming up and happening to the
kids and two adults let's take the
matter serious Salaam alaikum
we're told that children have the best
immune systems because they're there
they're fresh they're newborn why are we
seeing an increase in cancers in kids
that are that are younger would your mom
do you know there's a there's a school
of thought that you know they doesn't
really matter what the mother does and
there's even headlines now that you know
that you're all the mom can do this and
the mom can do this and it will not be
transferred to the fetus I don't think
that I believe that very much what the
mother does that the babies inside the
mother and what the mother does will
directly affect that child if she
doesn't nurse it will affect the immune
system and in the development of that
immune system and above and beyond that
have you seen what our kids eat today
and we're seeing kids with more cancers
because the mom drank Diet pop why do
you see young kids with brain cancers
now you think he hasn't had enough time
to develop it yeah he has
while cancer might take five years or 10
years or 15 or 20 years in some cases to
develop in your MOT in your body things
can be transferred from mother to child
and other cancers can can be very
rapidly spreading and grow fast our kids
drink 1/2 liter pops today they're
getting osteoporosis in their teens
because of the phosphoric acid it's 2.5
ph so they are acidifying their bodies
at a very rapid rate some of them are
drinking diet pop so they don't get the
calories diet pop actually helps you put
on weight and it has a spark aim in it
aspartame is new
sweeeeet NutraSweet is a very aggressive
neurotoxin it should have never been
approved ever if you talk to Betty
martini who sits on her Advisory Board
she leads the world in the fight against
aspartame she travels the world talking
about it should never have been approved
and it's killing our children and our
adults and and I see it happen just
continually people that become paralyzed
people that are diagnosed with lupus and
fibromyalgia and the catch-all MS when
the doctor can't figure it out
must be MS crying out loud folks
arthritis diabetes all these other
things we've discussed their food
diseases we know how to heal them today
all of them and and children have just
fallen victim they've fallen victim to
their mother's activities they've fallen
victim to these these diets
this lack of transfer factors all of
this plays into it you said most people
don't know where the doctors don't know
what cancer is and your research what is
it what have you found
well cancer is something we give
ourselves and doctors and researchers
want to say that no it's genes it's
we're mapping the human genome you know
that's where we're gonna find that cure
for cancer well they're not they're not
gonna find it there because the cause
doesn't lie there and what happens in
the human body is a result of how the
owner treats it and we as Americans have
unfortunately and I love America and I
love Americans but we've kind of become
a fat lazy country and we need to do
something about that because when we do
the right things we don't get cancer
cancer is proliferating today for a
reason we're drinking way too much soda
pop we're drinking drinking diet pop and
if you want brain cancer drink diet pop
I can almost guarantee you that over
time you will get it so we're doing all
the wrong things we put lotions and
potions and and what we wash our hair
with on our body they're all carcinogens
unless you're buying something that's
natural we drink fluoridated water
fluoride is a deadly poison it will kill
you as well
over time chlorinated water we take
showers and chlorinated water we cook
our food to death that destroys all the
goodness in our food we don't eat any
raw food you know raw carrot kids not
gonna eat a raw carrot he's been taught
not to french fries are not a vegetable
yet they're taught they are so we give
cancer to ourselves by how we treat our
bodies and it causes the body to acidify
and when your body gets acid all these
foods and drinks are acidic they near
your inner environment and your body
becomes acid and guess what pathogens
thrive in acidity when you're in a
clinical environment doing research and
you're you're testing pathogens what do
you do you put acid in there first in
that little beaker whatever because they
grow an acid if you put it in an
alkaline it wouldn't grow and so it
would kill it alkaline body is
uninhabitable for cancer and all other
diseases doctors should know this but
almost all Americans are a city and
that's the reason why we're so sick and
getting sicker we need to stop that my
name is sergeant Rick Schiff I'm an 11
year veteran of the San Francisco Police
Department
I hold the department's highest Medal of
Honor for bravery that used to mean a
lot more to me than it does now what I'd
like to talk to you about today is my
now seven year old daughter this is an
identical twin her sister is now dead
her sister when she was four years old
Kristin developed a highly malignant
brain tumor that had spread throughout
her spine in her brain the doctors told
us that we had really two options take
her home let her die or bring her in for
massive dosages of chemo and radiation
simultaneously in either event she was
going to die they were quite certain of
that and very quickly believing her only
chance to be the standard route we gave
her the chemo and radiation it burned
her skull so bad she had second-degree
burns and her hair never came back to
change her diapers we had to wear rubber
gloves because her urine was so toxic
and it burned her at the end of six
months miraculously she survived the
standard treatment although the
was a high expectation she wouldn't she
still had cancer
we were told sorry we've done everything
we can now she's gonna die probably
within a couple of months my wife and I
choosing not to accept that started
reading the first book I picked up the
third chapter discussed dr. Burzynski as
you may guess I have some expertise in
fraud in fact I'm quite certain there
enough attorneys in the room that could
be bored eared as an expert in fraud and
I conducted my own investigation
I have no doubt the man is not a fraud I
have no doubt that he does what he does
out of earnest belief that his medicine
works and now you're in a position to
judge for yourselves whether it works or
not but it's well established by the FDA
that it's non-toxic 18 months later we
took my daughter off the antineoplaston
she had not died she had no signs of
tumor she remained free for 18 months of
cancer within a month the cancer was
widespread in her brain we put her back
on Burzynski's by the way at the
objections of our doctors for some
reason felt that it had failed her they
put her back on within nine weeks the
tumor was completely gone she died last
July of neurological necrosis her brain
fell apart from the radiation the
autopsy showed that she was completely
cancer-free out of 52 cases of that
disease ever no one died cancer-free
just Chrissy so she didn't die of a
terminal illness she died of my
inability to care for her properly and
she died from bad advice
she died because there's a government
institution that disseminates false
information and is not looking out for
the welfare of the people you know
ladies and gentlemen I swore an oath 11
years ago and I think most of us in this
room swore at one time or another to
uphold the Constitution it says life
right in the beginning
[Music]